[Musique]
selon le journal ont arrêté suspendant
très la rivière
le 22 septembre 1668 quelques
autochtones cris de la baie james ont vu
ceci un petit navire britannique baptisé
le nom de sawtche en mission
d'exploration pour ce qui allait devenir
la compagnie de la baie d'hudson
grâce aux deux aventuriers français
médard choix sur des groseillers et
pierre esprit radisson ancien mari sinon
il n'y avait pas vraiment le village
c'est une place de choix de pêche qu'il
ya peut-être des petits campements des
tipis de fumée peut-être l'a fait mais
aussi c'est bien ce que les marins
anglais au feu de la fumée
le capitaine zakaria guilham l'a écrit
dans son journal le 22 septembre nous
avons vu de la fumée à terre nous avons
tiré un coup de feu des indiens se sont
approchés avec lesquels nous avons eu
quelques petits commerces et ils sont
partis
[Musique]
écrits de waskaganish appel ce moment le
premier contact
un contact qui allait bouleverser le
mode de vie des autochtones aient changé
l'histoire du futur canada
cette année la compagnie de la baie
d'hudson célèbre les 350 ans de son acte
fondateur
elle a régné sur le tiers du territoire
canadien actuel les crises veulent faire
reconnaître le rôle indispensable qu'ils
ont joué dans cette longue aventure qui
a façonné ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui un
peuple autonome fier de ses racines sa
culture ses traditions et sa langue
[Musique]
charles leicester et le responsable des
sports et culture au conseil de bande de
waskaganish c'est lui qui organise les
activités du 350e anniversaire du
premier contact
la première magasin de temps en 1987 la
baie de son vent ses comptoirs de traite
à la compagnie northwest propriétaire
des magasins order c'était le trading
poste change de 3,3 en 12 ans s'était
jamais fait records
[Musique]
on
il faut aller à winnipeg pour trouver
les archives de la compagnie de la baie
d'hudson ses voûtes renferme un trésor
national unique vu dans son ensemble il
n'y a pas de collection semblables dans
le monde sauf certaines archives
gouvernementales
voici le journal de pierre esprit
radisson 1683 sur cette page le 24
octobre 1671
on voit que le dernier point c'est le
paiement de 5 livres à radisson et des
groseillers pour leurs frais le registre
de tous les mouvements de navires de la
compagnie pendant 200 ans
l'état des glaces sur la baie d'hudson
était aussi noter tous les jours ce qui
en fait un document exceptionnel pour
l'étude des changements climatiques
on peut y lire que la baie était libre
de glaces de six à huit semaines
aujourd'hui elle le serait pendant 16
semaines un dictionnaire anglais écrit
illustré et en couleurs déniché par
notre archivistes et les archivistes ne
le font pas souvent mais cette fois là
j'ai dit waouh
[Musique]
aussi dans les archives des images
exceptionnelles datant de 1920
charles esther et ses collègues ont
demandé les archives correspondant tard
open house l'ancien nom de waskaganish
on leur a remis 10 boîtes il en reste 3
à explorer ce voyage dans le temps les
fascine sur ces onze années de suite 68
le 20 avril
ce qui intéresse les crises et de
reconstituer la vie de leurs ancêtres
ces chasseurs qui ont enrichi la
compagnie grand père m'a dit que cet art
c'est à ne rien y cacher ans tracera les
ténors se souvient de la flat six
arrivées deux mains de gouverneurs qui
reste elle aménage à quelques pas des
archives au musée du manitoba nos
visiteurs cris s'apprête à revivre le
premier contact des meilleurs une
réplique fidèle du non-stop grandeur
nature a été commandé par la compagnie
de la baie d'hudson pour son 300e
anniversaire en 1973 le navire est
transporté jusqu'au coeur des prairies
est offert au musée du manitoba à
winnipeg
ce petit navire avait à son bord un
équipage d'une dizaine d'hommes et
l'explorateur des groseillers
desgroseillers son jeune beau-frère à 10
ans avait tenté de convaincre le
gouverneur de la nouvelle france
d'ouvrir des postes de traite de
fourrure sur les rives de la baie du
sens mais en vain ils se sont alors
tournés vers les anglais qui eux ont
accepté de collaborer à leur entreprise
des groseillers à prouver que l'accès
aux plus belle fourrure d'amérique était
plus facile par l'abbé du son et que les
cris étaient accueillants ça m'a demandé
beaucoup de questions kretel réaction de
mon club à la première fois que j'ai vu
le bateau je pense que le tbb peu supris
chaque mêmes parce que jamais vu quelque
chose de cette grande arava arrivé à
waskaganish desgroseillers et l'équipage
construisent des habitations non
seulement les autochtones les nourrices
pendant l'hiver mais ils leur permettent
de rapporter à londres une riche
cargaison de fous rires ça pour ça que
l'on va venir
c'est là l'erreur est très beau et c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont fondé le cabinet bdo
ça concède sa est apte à santander 0 à
caen ce n'est as fait beaucoup d'argent
avec le trip ce qu'on a fait avec les
autres enrichissements mutuels
ou bien soumission coloniale cette
question hante les trois cent cinquante
ans d'histoire des relations de la
compagnie de la baie d'hudson avec les
autochtones
[Musique]
le camion a fait le trajet de winnipeg à
waskaganish au sud de la baie james
il transporte un colis chargée de
symboles pour la petite communauté crie
pour le 350e anniversaire de l'arrivée
du nantes ce match le musée du manitoba
a fait cadeau d'une maquette du navire à
la communauté crie de waskaganish la
réplique est dévoilée devant les anciens
et une bonne partie du village
ça ne plaît pas à tout le monde
am studio de nom de l'écrit ont-ils été
exploité par l'abbé du temps
les avis sont partagés honnêtement je
crois que la compagnie de l'habitude son
a été bonne pour les autochtones
elle leur a donné des emplois une source
de revenus en échange de leur fourrure
ils les ont aidés vers 1940 les animaux
se sont fait rares la compagnie a
contribué à restaurer les populations de
castor elle a également préservé
plusieurs familles de trappeur de la
famine
il y à cette histoire que la compagnie
exiger un tas de fourrure aussi haute
que la taille d'un fusil c'est une
histoire douteuses tous les documents
indiquent que la compagnie de la base
sont était équitable plusieurs siècles
de traite avec le jeu de la concurrence
avec des comptoirs français ont fait des
cris de waskaganish de bons négociateurs
ce moment ça a aidé beaucoup parce que
ça fait 300 355 en fait ça va arrêter
les aurais bien qu'un canard hydro
québec arrive à nos portes on a déjà eu
l'expérience de faire des négociations
avec les grandes compagnies comme
benneteau c'était moi c'était une chose
d'ouvert drones dans le petit cimetière
domine la tombe de billy diamond la
convention de la baie james
c'est lui qui l'a négocié whissell au
zoo qui contrôle un territoire c'est
nous autres qui contrôle nos affaires
et ça ça ça aide beaucoup
l'entente de la baie james et encore le
modèle la référence en matière
d'autonomie de gouvernement dans les
affaires la culture la langue
le mode de vie traditionnel de chasse et
de bâches et puis 350 ans les cris de
waskaganish prennent plaisir à souligner
qu'on a trouvé des traces de leur
présence depuis 4000 ans